I mean it's so much more like easier to
say like oh it's just perspective but
like on the daily when things are
happening and I know you're middle of
doing something I'll say for your
business who do you love the most in the
world my family
good who in your family pick one you're
very politically correct cool every day
make book in the midden like literally
once a day genuinely sit there for five
minutes and make pretend one of them got
shot in the face I'm being dead serious
with you every single day I almost I
said this today earlier I probably once
a week to four times a week sit there
coolly in the shower on a flight when I
wake up some people meditate right some
people work out right to deal with
whatever anxieties or thoughts have I
actually sit and coolly try to convince
myself that I have lost one of the five
most important people in my life and
that is the biggest thing I do that
leads to the biggest happiness I have
like what you sell enough earrings today
like seriously though people lack
perspective it's actually remarkably
easy if it became if it becomes the way
you see the world like what what like we
have completely lost perspective as a
society do many people on earth have it
way worse than you
billions
[Music]
I have one question
yep ask you and first of all thank you
on the same basis of him for giving me a
framework to life and also making me
feel not crazy with how much time I
wanted to spend on my music and what not
what you know it's really crazy to me
just says how I heard that I actually
think there's nothing the four of you
could be doing that's crazy
given how old you are I really [ __ ]
believe that I actually think nothing
anybody does under 35 is crazy
I think it's practical to scratch every
itch early on because you don't have any
rationale or reason to create
restrictions for yourself like family
and financial debt outside of Cup that's
why I hate college that I think it
eliminates your freedom you know it
eliminates your freedom if you have a
child or you buy something you limit
yourself or you or you have a partner
like it's like you store like there's
three variables that can start pulling
from a place where you can't be a
hundred percent selfish around your
happiness graph which is you have to
have empathy for your partner you have
the parent or you have to pay a bill
what are some of your daily habits that
you do daily to keep you as on point and
make pretend that my family dies you
make pretend that your family dies
there's something I do maybe not every
day but comes through my head pretty
often if you ask me why on me it's
because every day every other day no
shorter than minimum once every four
days I will roleplay in my mind the
tragic death of somebody in my inner
family really really okay and what do
you do with that information what I do
with that information is I use it as the
framework to keep everything in
perspective
it's really easy for me to be okay with
the three bad news things that I got
today about lost revenue at Vayner when
yesterday I made pretend that a tree
landed on my dad's head and killed him
I'm being serious
I know it's back to ice a different [ __ ]
I really mean what I'm talking about and
because I'm good with feeling feelings
with myself it really works because I
get really sad and scared and I really
don't want that to happen and then I'm
super thankful that that didn't happen
and everything else is you know one of
my best friends lost his father last
night really liked it and he's really
really sad and all the [ __ ] we've been
talking about for the last year around
business and other things just
miraculously didn't matter at all for
last three months that he's been in
hospital every day and every second just
doesn't [ __ ] matter so if that's what
we all do when it happens why not live
like that when it doesn't happen there's
no question that I am much happier than
the majority of the universe because of
perspective and it is completely
predicated on the singular variable of
health of the people I love
[Music]
how are you good and are you good
we're doing well what's your question hi
like third podcasted miss on my talking
about my community and the local
businesses okay there's one that's
possible
it is do you live in America I live in
that okay I'm watching good
the answer is it's possible okay so
should I just like start with like yep
yes yes Alex let me ask you a question
are you looking for affirmation are you
help me help you
like the intro are you asking if it's a
good idea like tell me what you're doing
here right now the answer is yeah how
old are you 25 awesome and you're and
you're doing this because you want to be
an entrepreneur and you've heard me or
others talk about podcasts /local and
you putting the pieces together and
you're like you can see a world where
you're interviewing local businesses or
people like you feel good about that
yeah I think that'd be great to get like
local businesses that we have out there
good and and and is your concern that
it's too narrow and you might not get
enough ad revenue and then thus it at
some point won't eat yeah so let me give
you an answer
the answer is yes now that I've asked
those questions here's why one you need
the experience and thinking about it is
never better than doing it doing always
beats thinking
yeah the end I mean our phone call was
almost you know luckily I was in the
mood but there was a part of me that was
like halfway home to just hanging up on
you because it's a good way just being
yes and that's it to make a point for
the audience and to you we're sticking
out and being a little calmer today but
like it's yes do it bro
just do it like I don't I don't I mean
you're in [ __ ] Nike country just do
it
you're the Pacific Northwest you guys
understand that [ __ ] motto just
[ __ ] make like all this overthinking
like I'm just so tired of everybody
overthinking whether it was the best use
of your time or not actually doing it is
better like people spend so much time
debating that even if they would have
done the wrong thing they they still had
more time on their hand I like doing and
finding out I'm wrong and still saving
time everyone so values their time or
they're so insecure about people judging
their decision that they will [ __ ]
make
I don't I want people to love their game
the way I love it not get the accolades
or success that I have because the
happiness is way more fun than a
byproduct and I know a ton of people who
are unbelievably happy and make forty
nine thousand a year and I know an
enormous amount of people who are deeply
unhappy and sick who make seven million
dollars a year and something I've been
saying a lot and I want to see more
often there was always that joke that
people talked about like around always
valuing money and they talked about
I'd rather cry in my Ferrari right and I
that that's saying always pissed me off
right this notion that okay you're
crying you're deeply unhappy and the
Ferrari versus a Toyota is supposed to
be some sort of variable there it's it's
such insane bad talk everybody should
aspire to be smiling in their Toyota if
you find out and understand yourself and
you put yourself in the best position
and you happen to have talent and you
put in a ridiculous amount of work then
you might be able to smile in your
Ferrari and that's amazing too
but these are the things that are
running through my head and I appreciate
you having a written tonight thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been hanging out with a hundred
I've been hanging out with Booga I know
you know what's that all about
keep going brow for night is long-term
and it's not the skills you learn on for
tonight will be applicable to other
things keep going
thank you see you soon sure
Pasquale we're taking a bud okay so I'm
in college right now in June Eric
yes on what on YouTube
Wow yeah and 100 of college
well you'll have another year right a
year and a half I don't know two years
you just started you should quit you
have to live your life that's true you
don't want to end up resenting them that
makes sense like there's two things the
most common things when somebody can't
find their passion is one they're over
putting pressure on finding their
passion and it becomes like this
convoluted [ __ ] whole thing and two
they just haven't tried enough [ __ ] have
you ever have you ever tried to cook a
gourmet meal like you know like you know
and I could probably sit here for the
rest of my life and give you eight like
people you know it's so heady but like
there's there's tasting [ __ ] that I call
tasting [ __ ] which is that like
literally saving up 180 bucks going and
buy and [ __ ] like expensive [ __ ]
food and try and like make it and also
you're like oh [ __ ] I'm a chef like the
biggest thing is people don't do [ __ ]
they don't do [ __ ] they stay in such a
lane or they make it so heady you know
you need me right
[Music]
yes cool man
listen keep me updated on it I love the
drys email Twitter's real good tried me
going to time saver [ __ ] up two times
they [ __ ] enough with and you got a
patriot logo unacceptable see missing
alright bye guys thank you
[Music]
I also love gemstones crystals and
whatnot you need a tourmaline
what's a tourmaline what it does is it
looks like a piece of coal but when you
put it in your pocket all the negative
energy that goes to you the stone pushes
back against them but I'm doing that
naturally what's it called a Toma know
what tourmaline I might be a human
tourmaline let's say I'll get one but
I'm gonna give you a real preview I'll
send you one I will take it and now I'm
gonna give you the preview thank you
no no let me give it to you okay I will
100% lose it within 48 hours
[Music]